We have a voicemail number. That number is
2 1 9 2. David P.. Here is a voicemail criticizing
me for a big faux pas I made when talking
about my urban garden on stream yesterday.
Take a listen to this.
Hello, David. I saw your show today and I
love your show. You said today that you were
getting from you had your raised beds, Bill,
and you were bringing in some dirt. Yes. And
then you wondered if you should call us soil.
Dirt is what you wash off of your hands and
soil is alive, medium and just wait and grow
your vegetables. Got it. Thank you.
Yeah. So I clearly m a beda male gardener.
I don't pretend to be an expert in gardening.
And I had it when I said that I was having
dirt delivered to grow vegetables. My instinct
was that that wasn't the right term. And indeed
it is not. I am having a beautiful soil delivery
this weekend. I'm going to plant much in the
style of Howard Dean. We're going to plant
carrots and we're going to plant peppers and
we're going to plant tomatoes and we're going
all the way to the fall with vegetables.
So follow the adventure on Instagram at David
Pakman. The planting starts very soon. The
soil is imminently going to be delivered and
it's going to be very, very exciting.
And it is just something not related to the
virus, which I think we all desperately need
right now. Don't miss today's bonus show.
Get instant access to it by being a member
or a patron. I'll talk to you that.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dot com.